[MUSIC PLAYING]
RYAN MATSUMOTO:
Cloud computing has
helped many industries
innovate to new heights,
and healthcare is no exception.
In previous videos
in this series,
we looked at how
the Cloud Healthcare
API can help you store
and access healthcare
data in Google Cloud.
In this episode, we'll explore
how the Cloud Healthcare
API can be used to store,
retrieve, and analyze
medical imaging data.
There are several key challenges
that healthcare professionals
face when dealing
with medical imaging.
First, you need to
ensure HIPAA compliance
in clinical workflows to
ensure patient privacy.
Second, researchers
often have to learn
about new technologies, which
can be confusing and expensive.
And third, it can be
difficult to leverage
this data to gain
important insights using
big data and machine learning.
Luckily, the Cloud
Healthcare API
addresses these challenges
with one of its endpoints
and comes packed with
other helpful features
for medical imaging analysis.
It supports Digital Imaging
and Communications In Medicine,
also known as DICOM, an
international standard file
format used for storing and
transmitting medical images
across technologies.
This could include x-rays,
MRIs, ultrasounds, and more.
It can also help you save
money by enhancing or even
removing the need for
specific on-premise software
that requires expensive
licensing fees.
And it makes it easy to
scale customer architectures,
while maintaining low
latency and high performance.
The Cloud Healthcare
API also helps
you leverage the power
of machine learning
by integrating well with Vertex
AI, Google Cloud's unified AI
platform.
And finally, it connects
easily with open-source tools,
like the Open Health Imaging
Foundation Viewer, also known
as the OHIF Viewer, which
lets you view medical images
for the purpose of analysis.
This is because the
Cloud Healthcare
API exposes the DICOM store
through a DICOM web interface.
Users who might be interested
in using the Cloud Healthcare
API for imaging
include radiologists
who may want to view images,
researchers and data scientists
who may want to use
images for diagnostics,
and IT decision-makers in
clinical organizations who
are looking to reduce costs
and improve storage, scale,
and elasticity.
Let's take a look at an example
of how the Cloud Healthcare
API can be used to build a
spine detection machine learning
model using a small
set of DICOM CT images.
First, images are ingested
into a DICOM store.
A data store is simply
a place to store
a certain type of
healthcare data,
so a DICOM store is a place
to store DICOM medical images.
Next, we can view the images
from the DICOM store using
OHIF, an open-source medical
imaging and viewing tool that
integrates directly with the
Google Cloud Healthcare API.
Images can then be
parsed into metadata
and streamed to BigQuery
for further analysis.
BigQuery is Google Cloud's
large-scale data warehouse
that's great for
storing, analyzing,
and visualizing large datasets.
With metadata ingested
into BigQuery,
it becomes much easier to
search across a large amount
of image metadata that
wouldn't be readily
searchable in other systems.
For example, we could search
for the most recent 20 images
of lung cancer diagnosis.
Once our BigQuery
search is done,
we can use the
corresponding DICOM web path
to find the specific image
for further analysis.
The next step is to use filtered
export to export specific image
instances to Cloud
Storage, which
is used to store file
objects in the Cloud.
Filtered export is
useful because you
may want to export specific
images from a larger
dataset to Cloud Storage and
convert them from DICOM to PNG
or JPEG for further analysis.
Once the images are
in Cloud Storage,
we can then start
training our machine
learning model using these
images as our test dataset.
First, we can import the images
into Vertex AI as an object
detection dataset.
Vertex AI is Google
Cloud's unified machine
learning platform that makes it
easy to build and train machine
learning models on Google Cloud.
Then we can label these
test images directly
in Vertex AI using
the Cloud Console.
Here's where we can label images
that have a spine in them.
Once our test
dataset is ready, we
can start to train
our prediction model.
We can use AutoML,
which actually
does most of the work for us.
All we have to do is provide
a label training dataset,
and Google Cloud
automatically builds
us a machine learning
model that leverages
its powerful
computing resources.
No prior knowledge of
machine learning is required.
Once AutoML finishes
building the ML model,
we'll get an online
prediction endpoint
that can be used to
predict whether or not
new images have spines in them.
The final step is to use the
OHIF viewer to view images
from the Healthcare
API DICOM store
and use the online prediction
endpoint to give us
our ML predictions.
Here we have our image being
shown in the OHIF viewer.
Under Predictions, we
can click Find Spine
to call the online prediction
endpoint hosted on Vertex AI.
And since a spine is detected,
it is outlined with a box
directly in the
image viewer itself.
We can also take a look
at the JavaScript Console
to see what's going
on behind the scenes
when we hit Find Spine.
There are just two API calls.
The first API call is a render
request to the Cloud Healthcare
API, which we use to get a
rendered view of the image.
The second API call is
to an online prediction
endpoint hosted on Vertex AI.
This is what we use to
predict whether or not
there's a spine in the image.
The response we get back
includes confidence scores,
as well as bounding
box information
for the spine detected.
In the end, OHIF renders
the image as well as
the bounding box on
top of the image.
As you can see, the
Cloud Healthcare API
provides a powerful
platform to help you
analyze medical imaging data.
An important feature is
that it integrates well
with Google Cloud products
like BigQuery, Cloud Storage,
and Vertex AI,
giving you new ways
to gain invaluable insights
about medical imaging data
while complying with HIPPA and
other government regulations.
To learn more, visit
cloud.google.com/healthcare.
To get started, you'll need to
have a Google Cloud project.
If you don't have one,
we've included a link
to a trial account
with free credits
in this video subscription along
with other helpful resources.
And friends, if you found
this episode helpful,
please subscribe to the
channel to get notifications
of more healthcare episodes.
Cheers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]